on va évidemment passer au grand débat
de ce club et ce déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron qui est en
Jordanie aujourd'hui il poursuit ce
déplacement pour éviter une escalade au
Proche Orient et relancer le processus
de paix hier il a rencontré les
dirigeants israéliens et palestiniens on
regarde ça avec Nicolas fleur la France
pleinement solidaire d'Israël voilà le
message qu'Emmanuel Macron a voulu faire
passer hier devant Benjamin netaniaahou
il propose de bâtir une coalition
internationale pour lutter contre le
Hamas
sur le modle de l'alliance contre DAEs
je propose à nos partenaires
internationaux je l'ai évoqué avec vous
ce matin que nous puissions bâtir une
coalition régionale et internationale
pour lutter contre les groupes
terroristes qui nous menacent tous cette
coalition appliquerait-elle une
intervention militaire comme en Irak et
en Syrie face à daesh l'Élysée dit
vouloir seulement réfléchir au mode
d'action possible le Premier ministre
israélien lui appelle les pays
occidentaux à s'unir derrière lui
le Hamas met notre civilisation à
l'épreuve s'il sort vainqueur nous
perdrons tous ce serait un danger pour
l'Europe ce serait un danger pour tout
le
monde l'après-midi Emmanuel Macron s'est
rendu en 6 Jordani première visite sur
place d'un dirigeant occidental depuis
le début de la guerre et nouvel appel à
protéger les civils j'entend les
souffrances des populations civiles à
Gaza et pour la France rien ne serit les
justifier il faut reconnaître le droit
des Palestiniens à disposer d'un état
affirme le président seul moyen selon
lui de faire revenir un jour la paix
Mahmoud Abbas appelle lui à faire cesser
d'urgence les bombardements israéliens à
Gaza nous vous exhortons vous président
Emmanuel Macron et les pays membres du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU à faire
cesser cette agression contre notre
peuple
Emmanuel Macron poursuit sa série de
visite au Proche Orient aujourd'hui en
Jordanie Guillaume Ansel on le voit
Emmanuel Macron qui a donc hier
rencontré dirigeant israélien dirigeants
palestinien est-ce que la première étape
de ce déplacement est réussie selon vous
alors manifestement le président
français voulait trouver une forme
d'équilibre la question c'est que
Benjamin netanahou est
extraordinairement critiqué en Israël
pour l'échec total de sa politique
sécuritaire c'est quand même là-dessus
qu'il a gouverné qu'un gouvernement
d'extrême droite pendant des années et
de l'autre côté Mahmoud Abbas n'est
absolument plus reconnu comme
représentant des Palestiniens donc
finalement il s'est adressé à deux
personnage l'un issu quand même d'une
démocratie il faut le préciser par
rapport au Palestiniens et l'autre qui
est euh plutôt démonétisé et qui en tout
cas les Palestiniens ne se retrouvent
pas en lui mais pour l'image
internationale c'était important qu'il
montre que il ne parlait pas qu'à une
seule des parties ensuite quand il vient
quand il avance sa proposition de
coalition il faut comprendre de quoi il
parle évidemment il a jamais eu eu
l'idée d'envoyer l'armée française
lutter contre le Hamas mais son idée qui
n'est absolument pas comment dire
grotesque ça consiste à ne pas laisser
Israël seul face au Hamas exactement
comme on l'avait fait face à daesh qui
avait agressé plusieurs pays c'estàdire
c'est une coalition internationale qui
doit lutter contre le Hamas et le Hamas
ne peut plus jamais être un
interlocuteur reconnu de qui que ce soit
voilà c'est ça que proposait le
président Macron on voit bien au visage
de Benjamin netanahou qu'il est très
enthousiaste de cette solution d'autant
que lui joue son avenir politique
justement dans une guerre qu'il n'a pas
déclenché mais qu'il brandit tous les
matins et qui est peut-être sa seule
possibilité d'effacer l'humiliation pour
Israël d'avoir subi une attaque que
Israël n'avait jamais connu depuis la
guerre du Yom Kipour il y a 50 ans
aujourd'hui on va revenir vous nous avez
dit beaucoup de choses Guillaume Ansel
sur sur tous ces sujets visite réussie
première étape réussie en tout cas Steve
disit que que Emmanuel Macron parlait
aux Israéliens et aux Palestiniens j'ai
l'impression que Emmanuel Macron a
surtout parlé aux français c'était un
peu les Français parle le français la
France parle à la France Emmanuel Macron
prochean si j'avais envie de faire un
bon mot ce qui est vrai c'est que j'ai
suivi cette visite d'Emmanuel Macron via
les médias israéliens il y a eu cette
alors il y a eu le discours qui a été
retransmis et puis après on en a plus
parlé vous regardez aujourd'hui les les
journaux israéliens il n'en parle
quasiment pas la la le poids de la
France dans le conflit et le poids de la
France en Israël est presque nul ça
c'est important c'est un pays occidental
mais ça reste une puissance relativement
moyenne et surtout les Israéliens ne se
fi pas à ce que peut dire Emmanuel
Macron ce que peut dire la France
aujourd'hui dans le conflit qui oppose
mais c'est intéressant ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui en Israël la voix de la
France elle pèse pas elle est toujours
regardé comme le le pays des droits de
l'homme le pays qui qui a été frappé par
le terrorisme en 2015 donc ça compte
d'une certaine manière mais mais les
israéliens de toute façon les Israéliens
sont méfiants presque par nature ils
sont méfiants des Européens et des
Américains Israël a été construit après
la choix avec cette idée que c'est aux
Israéliens d'assurer leur défense par
eux-mêm et il ne compte pas sur les
américains ni sur les Européens pour
assurer leur propre défense alors je
mettrai des nuances parce qu'évidemment
il y a des Américains mais en tout cas
il y a cette philosophie et cette idée
que il ne faut pas se fier aux
puissanceces extérieur pour et bien
assurer la défense ni ni pour
s'impliquer dans un un éventuel
processus de paix au proche au
Moyen-Orient ouais sur sur le poids de
la France en en Israël Guillaume mansel
c'est c'est intéressant ce que nous dis
israël compte pas finalement sur la
France en fait ce qui est un peu
dramatique mais mais je vais le ramener
à une problématique plus général c'est
que la France n'a plus les moyens de ses
ambitions depuis longtemps et que en
réalité c'est pas la France qui contrait
c'est l'Union européenne parce
qu'aujourd'hui un des principaux
financeurs dans la région de tous les
programmes de reconstruction
développement économique et là la
question centrale on voit bien c'est
l'avenir du peuple palestinien il y a
deux interlocuteurs de poids où je dire
il y en a trois il y a les puissances
arabe fortuné du Qatar à l'Arabie
Saoudite est-ce qu'elles vont peser un
moment dans un processus et surtout
est-ce qu'elles vont acceptter de
financer des programme qui permettrait
aux Palestiniens de sortir de l'immense
camp de réfugié qui est devenu Gaza il y
a les États-Unis pour leur puissance
économique mais aussi pour leur lien
très fort avec Israël et dont on voit
bien que c'est la puissance étrangère la
plus importante pour Israël et puis il y
a l'Union européenne et l'Union
européenne quand elle cause à les moyens
de ses ambitions alors que la France
parle comme une super puissance alors
qu'en réalité comme le rappelit Steve
c'est une puissance moyenne qui quelque
part n'a pas compris avec la guerre en
Ukraine que si on ne s'alliait pas avec
les pays européens bah en fait notre
voix comptait de moins en moins mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui hier en tout cas
Emmanuel Macron il a pas fait ce que
l'Union européenne est incapable de
faire c'est-à-dire aller parler à tout
le monde avoir une voix une ligne alors
que l'Union européenne on a l'impression
que c'est pas très clair que ça part un
peu dans tous les sens alors c'est vrai
que les les dirigeants de l'Union
européenne de toute façon sont
systématiquement critiqué par les pays-
membres et en particulier par la France
donc ça ça ne les aide pas la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il y a une polémique
autour du sur la V derlen la présidente
de la Commission européenne que je
trouve assez veine parce que c'est elle
la première qui a dit l'attaque du Hamas
est insensé mais elle été critiqué aussi
mais elle a été critiquée de de de dans
tous les sens or en fait pour moi c'est
elle qui avait raison c'est qu'on n' pas
cherché le sens de l'attaque du Hamas et
aujourd'hui la principale difficulté
pour les Israéliens c'est que ils
veulent lutter contre le Hamas ce que
personne ne peut les empêcher de faire
ça me semble quand même naturel le Hamas
les a attaqué bestialement le 7 octobre
et donc ils veulent attaquer le Hamas
pour se défendre mais pour attaquer le
Hamas ils s'en prennent aux Palestiniens
dans la bande de Gaza presque 2lion et
demi de de de réfugiés qui sont je le
rappelle dans la plus grande prison à
ciel ouvert du monde ça n'a pas de sens
et c'est bien ça la question duurcela
von derleyen c'est réfléchissons à ce
que le Hamas a voulu faire il l'a pas
fait innocemment le Hamas il l'a pas
fait juste pour horrifier les Israéliens
il les a fait pour les provoquer or que
fait Israël sous la direction du
gouvernement netaniaou et ce qui est
très ennuyeux quand on veut faire la
guerre il va exactement là où l'ennemi
l'attend c'està-dire que Israël semble
vouloir se précipiter dans une offensive
terrestre contre la bande de Gaza or
c'est exactement ça que le Hamas attend
Israël confond le Hamas avec le peuple
palestinien c'est exactement ça dont as
besoin le Hamas pour recruter pendant 15
ans et pour soulever toutes les opinions
publiques contre Israël en disant vous
avez vu ils se comportte comme des
monstres ce qui serait quand même un
retournement de l'histoire incroyable
Israël est en train de tomber dans le
piège tendu par le Hamas je sais pas si
Israël confond le peuple palestinien et
le et le Hamas est-ce qu'il y a un piège
tendu par le Hamas c'est possible euh je
sais pas non plus si Israël se précipite
actuellement vers une incursion
terrestre ce serait peut-être plutôt le
contraire pour l'instant on voit que
Israël attend patiente sans doute parce
que les États-Unis et bien les retient
un peu par le col sans doute parce qu'il
y a les otages qui sont encore dans la
bande de Gaza et aussi sans doute parce
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une vraie crise de
confiance entre l'armée et l'échelon
politique en Israël c'est très très
difficile aujourd'hui de voir ce que
souhaite le gouvernement israélien et ce
que souhaite l'armée c'est très clair
l'armée tous les jours presque tous les
jours cette semaine à répéter nous
sommes prêts à entrer dans Gaza on
attend le feu vert de l'échel mais
leschev politique n'est pas n'est pas
unanime là-dessus Benjamin Nanou
lui-même c'est très difficile de savoir
ce qu'il veut Benyamin nou c'est pas
quelqu'un je l'ai déjà dit sur ce
plateau et ailleurs c'est pas quelqu'
c'est pas un VAT en guerre Benjamin tou
c'est quelqu'un qui utilise qui qui aime
les opérations spécial il appartient
lui-même il appartenait lui-même à une
unité d'élite la saette malcal c'est une
force spéciale qui opère derrière les
lignes ennemis et lui tendrait plutôt
vers bien des opérations commando des
opérations spéciales dans la bande de
Gaza avec des bombardements aériens mais
lui ne souhaiterait pas d'après ce qui
ce qui ce qui ressort une incursion
générale des 360000 réservistes
israéliens ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que en Israël c'est pas c'est pas une
armée professionnelle quand vous
mobilisez l'armée ce sont des civils qui
vont au front l'économie aujourd'hui
israélienne est presque à plat vous avez
la moitié de l'économie israélienne qui
est aujourd'hui fermée les écoles qui
sont fermé donc la décision la prise de
décision d'entrer dans Gaza est très
lourde de sens pour Benjamin mais pour
l'ensemble du gouvernement de manière
générale j'jouterai un dernier truc on a
appris avanttiier que le gouvernement
israélien n'avait ces 15 dernières
années pas demandé à l'armée de faire un
rapport sur une éadication du Hamas
c'està dire que ça fait 15 ans que
Benjamin et est au pouvoir et qui nous
dit qu'il va éradiquer le Hamas un
ministre s'est exprimé il y a de jours
en disant jamais aucun gouvernement
israélien n'a demander à l'armée de
préparer un plan militaire pour
éradiquer le Hamas donc on est là dans
un moment de réflexion de préparation et
peut-être ou pas d'incursion terrestre
dans Gaza ouais et on va revenir sur sur
les deux sujets dont vous avez parlé St
Guillaume hsel d'abord est-ce qu'il y a
des tergiversations du côté de Benjamin
nthaniao Steve le rappelait les
réservistes sont mobilisés depuis des
jours ça fait plus de 10 jours que
Israël demande d'évacuation la bande de
Gaza des populations civiles en vue
d'une opération terrestre qui n'arrive
toujours pas pourquoi
alors trois choses la la première c'est
que il y a des tensions très fortes y
compris au sein de l'armée moi mais sour
israélienne me disent au sein de
t on comprend pas les objectifs
militaires et c'est ce qu'a rappelé Joe
Biden la semaine dernière dans sa visite
vous devez éclaircir vos objectifs
militaires pourquoi parce qu'il prend
l'exemple du 11 septembre on se souvient
quand même c'est l'exemple le plus
récent que c'est pas en envahissant
l'Afghanistan que les Américains ont
réussi à chasser les talibans et ils en
ont pris un échec considérable qui a
sans doute était un des facteurs
d'ailleurs d'origine de de la guerre en
Ukraine donc les Américains essayent de
ramener à la raison là je parle de
militaire à militaire sont les
militaires américains qui parlent à Sal
pour leur dire mais vous allez faire
quoi dans la bande de Gaza ils ont même
envoyé un général conseil l'armée
israélienne et et et les échanges sont
très intenses sur le sujet mais
attention quand Steve dit ils se
retiennent sur une opération terrestre
par contre ils se retiennent pas sur
l'opération de bombardement ils font
plusieurs centaines de bombardements par
jour ce qui est absolument colossal et
normalement ça c'est une opération de
préparation une invasion qu'on fait
pendant quelques jours quelques jours
c'est dire moins d'une semaine puis
après on env s'ils envillissent pas
c'est clairement qu'ils sont retenus
pour les raisons qui a évoquétif mais il
y a une troisième raison c'est que
l'opération qu'a lancé au départ le
Hamas le 7 octobre n'est pas à leur
portée le Hamas ne sa'est pas organiser
une opération combinée de cette ampleur
qui a totalement surpris l'armée
israélienne totalement surpris les
renseignements enfin en partie
totalement surpris le système de
commandement des Israéliens et qui ont
mis plusieurs heures à réagir alors que
dans une opération comme ça le fait de
de réagir très vite et primordial c'est
le problème des pompiers face à un feu
c'est les 10 premières minutes qui
comptent c'est les deux premières heures
d'une incursion où on peut empêcher les
gens de commet des dégâts donc l'armée
israélienne a été totalement comment
dire dépassée par les événements et en
face c'est pas le Hamas qui était
capable de le faire on sait qu'il y
avait un autre acteur on se doute qu' a
l'Iran c'est évident mais pour moi il y
a un autre acteur beaucoup plus
important c'est la Russie les méthode
qu'a utilisé le Hamas cette combinaison
de moyens pas sophistiqué mais en très
grand nombre avec des technique de
combat particulièrement violente et
brutale ça ressemble étrangement à ce
que fait à ce que faisait Wagner en
Afrique il y a quelque chose de très
troublant dans la manière dont ont été
conduit les opérations et ce que je
trouve encore plus terrible aujourd'hui
c'est la manière dont le Hamas provoque
systématiquement Israël pour obliger
Israël à faire cette erreurs fatales qui
seraiit de rentrer longuement sur le
territoire de Gaza on voit bien que
quand le ministre de la Défense dit on
va rester c'est une guerre qui va durer
des mois peut-être des années mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire une fois
qu'ils seront dans la bande de Gaza
surtout une fois que l'essentiel de la
bande de Gaza qui est urbanisé sera
détruite mais tenir dans des décombres
c'est impossible c'est des combats au
quotidien qui feront des morts du côté
israélien et chaque fois qu'ils tireront
un coup de feu ils feront 5q victimes
civiles donc ça n'est pas tenable et ils
le savent l'armée le sait donc la
question c'est c'est quoi leurs vrais
objectifs pour essayer de détruire le
Hamas pour l'instant ils ne les ont pas
déterminé
oui c'est ce que dit effectivement aussi
l'armée américaine et puis Joe Biden qui
donc a envoyé un général qui a opéré en
Syrie et qui a opéré en Irak et donc les
Américains en sont très conscients et
disent très clairement aux Israéliens
aujourd'hui faites attention cette
opération terrestre que vous envisagez
il faut délimiter les objectifs qui ne
sont pas délimités c'est très facile de
dire on va éradiquer le Hamas mais vous
avez entre 20 et 30000 combattants
terroristes du du Hamas dans la bande d'
Gaza c'est pas très simple je parle sous
votre contrôle d'éliminer autant de de
de personnes en quelques enfin une
période très courte et aussi c'est
effectivement c'est ce que vous avez dit
c'est sur cette cette cette bande très
urbanisée dans des ruelles il y a le ce
qu'on appelle le fameux en en Israël on
appelle ça le tunnel du Hamas le métro
du Hamas qui en fait est un métro qui
qui est une galerie de tunnel qui passe
sous la bande de Gaza c'est très
compliqué d'arriver d'atteindre c'est
pour ça que si les bombardements se font
de plus en plus intensifs parce que ils
essayent effectivement de détruire les
même aussi d'atteindre ces tunnel et
c'est très très très compliqué et ce
qu'on entend aussi en Israël c'est que
euh cette opération ne ressemblera pas à
l'opération de 2014 où Israël était
entré dans Gaza était avait procédé de
maison maison après maison pour tuer des
terroristes là ce qu'on nous dit c'est
que ça va pas du tout ressembler à ça on
est ils évoquent 2 3 4 5 6 mois
d'opération terrestre une guerre longue
parce que certains évoque la possibilité
de et bien de de faire des incursions de
repartir de faire des incusssions de
repartir donc on ce qui en Israël on
s'attend à une guerre qui va être très
longue qui va faire qui va toucher
l'économie israélienne la politique
israélienne et de manière plus générale
le ProcheOrient et le Moyen-Orient en
fait il faut imaginer que à partir du
moment o on bombarde on détruit quand
Israël dit je fais des frappes ciblées
contre des terroristes du Hamas pardon
on peut pas le faire avec des bombes
guidées de 250 kg je vais prendre qu'un
exemple pour bien comprendre quand on
déclenche un tir d'artillerie il y en a
à peu près 200 qui sont déclenchés tous
les jours aujourd'hui c'est 30 obus de
45 kg donc faut imaginer ces 30 bombes
de 45 kg qui volatiliseraient une pièce
comme celle-ci qui tombe sur
l'équivalent d'un terrain de foot est-ce
que vous croyez que vous allez détruire
uniquement le ballon qui est au milieu
en détruisant un terrain de foot non
vous détruisez les deux équipes et donc
à chaque bombardement on fait plus de
victimes civiles que de ciblees
militaire cible militaire dont on
souvient que le Hamas n'a pas d'armée
elle n'a pas d'armée enendure avec des
chars avec des structures avec des
arsenaux qui permettraient ce qu'on a on
appelle des cibles dures dans l'armée
c'estàdire capable de les bombarder et
de les détruire là ce sont des civils
qui se transforment en combattant le
temps où ils prennent une kalalachnikov
et au moment où ils l'ont lâché ils sont
de nouveau civils déterminer qui sont à
l'intérieur d'une population civile est
impossible et donc cette méthode de
combat en tout cas ces bombardements
n'ont pas de sens quant à détruire les
tunnels les Américains on ont gardé une
cuisante expérience au Vietnam parce que
pour détruire un souterrain il faut
détruire ce qu'il y a au sol donc
l'alternative n'existe pas il faut tout
détruire sous 2 m de profondeur pour
empêcher les tunnels qui seront
recreusés dans la foulée ça n'a pas de
sens non plus ça ce sont des impasses ça
veut dire que le but initial de Benjamin
netanou anéantir le Hamas il ne pourra
pas être tenu il peut pas être tenu avec
une offensive militaire terrestre ça n'a
pas de sens et c'est en ça que la
réflexion des États-Unis puis celle de
la France qui finalement complète et se
met un peu dans le sillage des
États-Unis de dire un bien sûr on est là
pour vous aider mais il faut que vous
réfléchissiez dans un cadre
internationale à la manière dont on
s'attaque au Hamas aller bombarder la
bande de Gaza en disant qu'on va
détruire le Hamas n'a aucun sens ce
serait un peu comme quand les Américains
s'étaient mis en tête en Indochine de
tuer les les combattants
Nord-Vietnamiens en en défaisant
totalement la forêt au Laos et au
Cambodge 300000 tonnes de bombes qui
n'ont bien sûr permis qu'un échec d'où
la coalition dont vous nous parliez tout
à l'heure Guillaume Ansel euh vous nous
l'avez un peu dit mais on va reparler de
cette coalition puisque c'est c'est
l'une des phrases he qu'on retient du
déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
faire le parallèle entre daesh et le
Hamas c'est c'était
opportun probablement d'abord ça montre
que cette volonté des Occidentaux de
discréditer définitivement le Hamas le
Hamas ne peut plus être un interlocuteur
pour les pays occidentaux après ce
qu'elle a ce qu'ils ont fait à Israël
boucherie le le le le le les attaques de
début octobre ont été bestiales c'est
pas la peine de montrer les images tout
le monde a compris mais derrière il faut
le discréditer définitivement
effectivement lutter contre le Hamas
mais lutter contre le Hamas comme on l'a
fait pour daesh c'est lutter
financièrement c'est empêcher que le
Hamas puisse avoir des émissaires dans
le monde entier c'est empêcher que il
puisse avoir une influence dans d'autres
nations et ça posera la question du
Qatar de notre relation avec le Qatar où
je rappelle si onavz une carte je
montrerai c'est assez pousouflant il y a
quand même le quartier général du Hamas
qui est à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de la principale base
américaine dans la région donc que le
Qatar se mette en intermédiaire obligé
c'est bien mais en même temps c'est
d'une incroyable ambigué donc il a un
moment on pourra pas l'accepter c'est
comme s'il y avait le quartier général
de daesh qui était là juste à côté de
celui du
Hamas non je crois
que peut-être pour revenir sur sur sur
l'intervention de d'Emmanuel Macron qui
qui est donc en Jordani qui passera
peut-être en Égypte et qui ira peut-être
jusqu'à Riyad si c'est le cas ce sera
du point d'un point de vue diplomatique
en tout cas peut-être une réussite euh
parce que pour l'instant il y a pas on a
pour l'instant ça pas pour l'instant
voilà c'est les Français qui parlent au
français mais on va voir effectivement
s'il peut réactiver quelque chose dans
ce processus diplomatique en terme de
d'accord d'Abraham en terme de processus
de paix israëlo-palestinien mais pour
l'instant on a très peu on a très peu
d'éléments ce qui est bien c'est qu'il a
rappelé la nécessité d'un État
palestinien de deux états côte à côte on
connait les les paramètres on connait
les éléments en Israël il connait ces
éléments maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et avec qui c'est aussi ça
peut-être la question aujourd'hui oui
non mais vous allez vous me lancez
complètement puisque on va écouter
Emmanuel Macron qui effectivement hier
est allé voir marmou Abas sur cette
question des deux
états l'avenir de votre peuple de la
région passe enfin par une reprise
processus politique permettant à deux
étatsitant en pai enfin d'énergie voilà
Emmanuel Macron qui dit qui défend la
solution à à deux États qui dit qu'il
n'y aura pas de paix sans un État
palestinien et là ça repose la question
du moment est-ce que c'est le moment du
dialogue est-ce que c'est le moment de
se poser cette question pour les
Israéliens non sans doute pas pour les
Palestiniens non plus pour la France
c'est le moment en tout cas de le faire
et de remettre cette cette solution sur
sur la table alors on connaît les
paramètres ça ça a capoté plusieurs fois
on peut peut-être le rappeler ici ça a
capoté en 2000 ça a capoté la conférence
d'Annapolis en 2006 avec eoudolmert et
Marmoud Abbas qu'on qu'on vient de voir
il y avait beaucoup d'éléments qui
faisaient débat il y avit la question
des réfugiés palestiniens la question de
Jérusalem la question des frontières sur
ces trois éléments en 2006 on était plus
ou moins d'accord en tout cas il y avait
une proposition généreuse de la part
desoudolmer du gouvernement israélien et
ça pourrait être réactivé d'une certaine
manière mais effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit est-ce que le contexte est là
sans doute pas est-ce que ce sera avec
mmoud Abbas 88 ans sans doute pas non
plus mmoud Abbas on le rappelle
l'Autorité palestinienne qui finance des
terroristes du Hamas c'est le Hamas et
le Fatar ne ne s'entendent pas mais
quand un terroriste commet un attentat
l'Autorité palestinienne les finan
Marmoud Abbas 88 ans on imagine mal
arrivver à Gaza sur un char israélien
c'est pas du tout cette voil est-ce que
ce sera avec benamin Nania ah bah
benamin Nanou devra partir de toutes les
façons parce que benamin Nanou toute sa
politique a été de diviser les
Palestiniens pour empêcher la création
d'un État
palestinien le le le discours de Macron
était très construit et quand il
rencontre Mahmoud Abbas on voit bien je
suis trois phases qui sont parfaitement
logiques il dit un il y a la lutte
contre les groupes terroristes coalition
internationale de il y a la protection
des civils si Israël continue à
matraquer la population palestinienne de
toute façon les opinions publiques se
soulèveront contre elle et ce serait un
retournement incroyable de la situation
qu'on soit obligé de reprocher à Israël
une guerre qui a été déclenchée par une
attaque bestiale du Hamas c'est
exactement là où le Hamas veut l'emmener
et puis la troisième bien sûr c'est la
reprise d'un processus politique c'est
logique mais ça se fait dans cet ordre
là et en fait la première question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on lutte contre le
Hamas aujourd'hui pour moi Israël n'a
qu'une seule solution c'est surprendre
si elle va là où le Hamas l'attend elle
a perdu la guerre et donc ça n'est pas
la peine d'avoir fait saincir pour
comprendre que quand on fait la guerre
on ne va jamais là où son ennemi
l'attend et surtout pas au moment où il
l'attend sinon on a perdu mais est-ce
que euh l'attaque du Hamas l'attaque du
7 octobre euh n'a pas tué en tout cas
pour le moment la solution à deux état
ah bah elle était déjà morte euh la
l'attaque du 7 octobre elle a tué
beaucoup de de civils déjà 80 % de civil
il faut peut-être le rappeler 80 % de
civils israéliens euh et puis cette
solution à deux états elle est elle elle
avait été les Américains av essayé de la
réactiver en en 2014 échec total John
Kerry on s'en rappelle Barack Obama
presque humilié au Proche Orient et du
coup ils se sont dit bon on va laisser
ça de côté c'est vraiment pas pour nous
euh donc oui un peu une volonté de
mettre la poussière sous le tapis
finalement et aujourd'hui tout ça
ressurgit bah c'est la question
palestinenne qui ressurgit par la force
des choses par le drame qui s'est passé
par cette attaque terroriste bestial la
question palestinienne est remise sur le
devant de la scène donc les les les les
les
les populations occidentales les
dirigeants occidentaux doivent en tenir
compte notamment au Moyen-Orient avec
les alliés avec les avec les les pays et
les régimes arabes mais j'aimerais aussi
dire quelque chose c'est que on parle
beaucoup de de de la voix d'une voix
singulière qu'aurait la France dans
cette histoire et de mais il y a
quelqueose et ça ça fait un peu logiciel
des années 80 90 c'està dire qu'il faut
voir que depuis les révoltes arabes en
2011 le Moyen-Orient a complètement
changé et ça en France j'ai l'impression
qu'on l' on l'a un peu occulté depuis
2011 si vous voulez le Moyen-Orient
s'est complètement transformé il est
difficile aujourd'hui d'aller parler
avec les milistes outil au Yémen avec
les rebelles en Syrie ou d'aller parler
avec le Hezbollah qui a 150000 missiles
pointés vers Israël donc on peut dire il
faut une voix singulière il faut
relancer il faut relancer un processus
de paix qui est nécessaire mais il faut
aussi avoir en tête à quel point le
Moyen-Orient a complètement changé ces
20 dernières années et depuis les les
révolutions arabe et à quel point si
vous voulez il y a une une bestialité et
une une soif de sang dans cette région
qui avait peut-être déjà avant mais qui
a encore peut-être plus depuis une
dizaine d'années maintenant ouais un
dernier mot Guillaume Ansel il faut
parler des otages parce que les otages
sont une pièce dans la complexité de la
situation en Israël et aujourd'hui il y
a un risque sur les otages c'est que le
Hamas bien sûr les négocie petit morceau
par petit morceau c'est qu'en fait il ne
relâche que le Hamas ne relâche
finalement pratiquement que les otages
binationaux et ça ce serait monstrueux
vis-à-vis d'Israël de laisser Israël
seul face au Hamas avec un problème
d'otage qui serait uniquement israélien
et où tous les autres pays diraient
comme Joe Biden quand il a récupéré des
otages vous avez vu c'est formidable ce
que j'ai fait on oublie l'autre parce
que quelque part on a l'impression de
s'être sauver soi il faut qu'on soit
très attentif sur ce sujet des otages
parce qu'il est hyper sensible pour
Israël pour Israël qui a toujours
apporté une importance considérable à la
vie humaine on ne peut pas laisser
Israël seul face à ses otages au hamass
et on continuera évidemment à parler de
ce sujet merci messieurs on continue en
parler tout de suite puisque c'est à la
une de vos quotidienens
[Musique]
régionaux le déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron en Israël qui fait donc la une de
vos quotidiens régionaux ouest- France
fait le récit d'une journée sous tension
Macron entre guerre et paie ce sont les
mêmes mots choisis par la dépêche et
l'Alsace qui n'est pas la vie du journal
La Marseillaise Macron n'a dit ni le mot
trêve ni le mot paix titre le journal
dans ses pages intérieures avec
également cette photo ce rassemblement
des représentants des religions juives
catholiques musulmanes à l'initiative
des supporters de l'OM pour appeler au
dialogue et à la paix au Proche Orient
c'est une autre photo qu'a choisi M lip
celle d'Emmanuel Macron réconfortant les
proches des disparus franco-israéliens
l'envoyé spécial du Midi Libre en Israël
qui raconte aussi les réactions des
expatriés chez qui la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron suscitait de l' ir des expatriés
entre émotion et déception résume le
journal avec plusieurs réactions celle
d'Aron pour qui la présence du président
est très touchante qu'il soit venu en
personne c'est déjà beaucoup dit-il
celle de Jérémie plus partagé j'ai été
agréablement surpris du soutien sans
condition de Macron auprès d'Israël et
proportionnellement déçu qu'il parle de
relancer un processus français au de un
processus de paix pardon au moment même
où il y a plus de 200 otages dont neu
français Midi Libre qui titre son
article intérieur sur la proposition i
d'Emmanuel Macron de coalition antiamas
d'autres titres ce matin dans vos
journaux régionaux le Télégramme
s'alarme des difficultés financières des
épad d'pat comment sortir de la crise
titre le journal le modèle de
financement des épades publiques est
obsolète à la roche Judie dans les Côtes
d'Armor le directeur est un équilibriste
qui va chuter si la loi grand âge
promise par le gouvernement n'est pas
votée en urgence et le journal se
demande quelle solution pour sortir les
épades des difficultés financières un
tarif différencié pour les plus aisés ou
encore la pr d'une taxe sur les salaires
qu'ils appliquent aux éepad publics et
pas privés selon la Fédération
Hospitalière cette taxe elle augmente de
18 % le coût de la masse salariale de
ces établissements et puis c'est
l'inquiétude d'Air France à la Une de
cors matin 300 salariés de la compagnie
VO leur avenir menacer la délégation de
service public sur les lignes aériennes
entre cors et continent assuré par Air
France et Air Corsica arrive à échéance
fin décembre la candidature de la
compagnie espagnole lowcast Volotea
menace les 300 emplois d'Air France et
les 7 Corsica l'arrivée de volottea
serait pour tous un cataclysme écitore
ce matin une catastrophe pour les
familles et l'économie locale alerte les
représentants d'Air France qui attendent
des él corores du courage politique on
termine par du foot à la une de la voie
du Nord et le match nul de lance en
Ligue des Champions lance un point au
mental c'est le titre des
Nordistes Guillaume Ansel on regarde
votre blog tout de suite un mot de votre
blog j'essaie surtout de montrer que il
faut garder de l'optimisme en disant que
aujourd'hui même si les uns et les
autres affirment le contraire dans
Israël face au Hamas on a plutôt des
signes de désescalades voilà le fait que
des otages a été rendus et le fait que
des convois humanitaires aient pu
rentrer dans Gazin est extrêmement
important et contradictoire avec les
déclarations radicales des uns et des
autres merci Guillaume Encel Steve on
revoit votre livriselle autopsie d'une
gauche 1905- 1985 CX édition le bord de
l'eau merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi à 18h
vous avez R
pour s public on se retrouve
demain